thanks for joining us America Ruth is
with us in Cincinnati Ruth welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show thank you
how are you better than I deserve how
are you I'm good and you think for
answer my call sure I was wondering on
61,000 260 and we're wondering if it's
too late for us to retire mm before 70
because we don't have enough money in
retirement so I hear you have six or
seven hundred thousand to retire and we
don't have that kind of money we have
that and a little bit of spoiling pay
saving how much is in your 401 K um I
think there's only around like 76,000
how much does AFS we have with our house
- we have a core it has too many years
to be paid off I think we owe 10
thousands and we have um about 2004 debt
and we have a couple other debt so we
paid off in June what are they
one is a Care Credit it's a um pureed
I'm bill that we paid off in June and
it's um I think there's a thousand left
and we have um I think they did oh we
get where your hellos anything yeah you
guys are 61 yes and what are you owe on
your house um around 137 okay
that's good news okay all right well I
mean obviously the answer can't be no
because you're going to retire at some
level the question is what you're going
to be able to keep and what's going to
happen do you have another car
you guys both work I don't he does watch
out what does he make about 130 oh
that's good news okay and and how much
longer does he plan to work he says 20
drops over Jamie's afraid doesn't let me
retire well he's right he doesn't and he
makes way too much money for you all to
be this broke so what you guys need to
do is you need to get on a really beans
and rice rice and beans scorched earth
budget and get this stupid car and these
credit cards all paid off as fast as
possible build you an emergency fund and
then lay into that 401k good and heavy
at 15% of your income and I'm gonna
reach over and try to get that house
paid off too so but you really are not
going to go on vacation at all ever
again
until after you retire oh my you're way
behind and you need to get your house
paid off get these debts cleaned up and
throw another hundred or two hundred in
the good news is you make 130 I was
scared to death you were going to tell
me he makes thirty two thousand a year
well he hasn't always made that much um
just the past five years even in the six
but you've got nothing to show for it
right except the stinking car payment
and no money sorry I don't know where
you've been spending it but it's over
you know you're eating out all the time
or you're traveling I don't know what
you're doing but you guys have got to
get on a written budget for your sake I
don't care I mean you can do whatever
you want eh but you call me so if I'm in
your shoes I'm going yeah I got about 10
years of this seven years of this 130
thousand dollar income to pay off 137
thousand dollar mortgage to get some
money stuck in my 401 K my IRAs and get
these other little miscellaneous debts
cleaned up and have a little bit of cash
for an emergency and you can do a lot of
that you could you could literally have
a half a million dollars and have the
house paid off and have no debt but
you're going to do nothing else that's
all you're going to do but the good news
is then you got the rest of your life to
retire and actually enjoy your
retirement but if you keep spinning like
you've been spending and you stay
disorganized like you have been you're
going to retire on dog food and that's
what he's afraid of well
let's get afraid enough to do something
about it well he said he wanted to pay
off the house but in order to compare
off the house that would take money from
well here's the order here's the order
okay first thing I want you to is pay
off all these little debts the car and
the credit cards and these other things
list them smallest to largest that's the
first thing what you do then the second
thing I want you to do is build an
emergency fund a rainy day fund of three
to six months of expenses let me help
you with that in your case that's
$15,000 minimum in an emergency fund
now you're debt-free but the house and
you have fifteen thousand then you move
to baby step four we call it you start
putting fifteen percent of your income
that's $20,000 a year for you guys I
want you to start saving $20,000 a year
now what you throw the rest of it at the
house until the house is paid off once
the house is paid off I want you to
throw everything you can get your hands
on into retirement so that you can
retire I think if you do that I just did
the calculations in my head but I might
be wrong but if you work seven eight if
he works seven eight years nine years
more making this kind of money you'll
have a half a million dollars a paid-for
house and no debt but you're not going
on vacations you're not going on
vacation that's not good news you're not
eating now unless you're working there I
know is one of you when was the last
time you won years there was last time
you know what um I don't know probably
actually I were part-time like 20 years
ago okay all right I mean if you're if
you're able I don't mind you going and
doing something too because you throw
another thirty fifty thousand bucks in
this equation a year offer you all
sudden we got some serious money to
clean this thing up with and we can turn
it around this is doable but you guys
are going to get very very serious today
and you're not buying nothing
nothing nothing nothing so that you can
retire with dignity but I'll help you
with this hold on I've got to send you a
copy of our book the Total Money
Makeover you and him sit and go through
that book and it'll show you exactly
what I'm talking about I'll give that to
use my gift
there you go turn your life around let
me know how you're doing - if you need
some help along the way you call me I'll
help you
you